[Music]
eddie's in philadelphia hey eddie
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave dr john honor to speak with you
guys you too what's up
so uh my question to you is my i'm
getting married in about a month and a
half and my fiance
just started a very expensive master's
degree program but she also wants to be
a stay-at-home mom
i'm not sure how to handle this
well why are you waiting until a month
and a half before marriage to address
something that's serious
well we have been addressing this um no
we haven't sounds like she has you
haven't
well we've both
we this is has definitely been a point
of
i guess you could say contention since
we
um
we've been together for six years so
this master's program started two months
ago and we have had extensive
conversations about it
um but i didn't really want to be the
person to hold her back from doing it
especially before we were even engaged
so i kept my opinion to a minimum
because i didn't want to be that person
who held her back from her dreams um but
let me just tell you if you're if the
person you loves dream is really a
nightmare you should say something
i completely agree and
we have had um several conversations
with my parents
and her parents about
the situation and we're just not really
getting anywhere
what's that what's the program
it's a master's in nutrition degree okay
and what's what in her heart
says she wants to do
um well there were two questions there
um it's i'm not really sure why it's so
expensive but it costs about 60 000 just
for the tuition after her scholarships
and it's uh
what's expensive because people will pay
it but go ahead right yeah it's
definitely one of the more expensive
institutions in the city
um and
yeah that's kind of what why does she
want why does she need this why does she
want to do this
well
the way she was raised um there's always
been high value on education and
attaining getting that next degree
there are a lot of different reasons why
but she obviously doesn't want to let
her parents down she feels like she's a
very smart girl which she is um and
this will kind of be like a status
elevation thing and
it's a topic that is just very
interesting for her yeah those are her
reasons for wanting to so
are you all taking out loans for this
thing you're paying for it in cash so
not yet that's kind of where the
contentions come into play because i've
sat down with her and tried to map out a
plan of okay who's paying for this
you know are your parents going to help
and am i kind of footing the bill for
the whole thing
and unfortunately her parents recently
had a split a divorce like two months
ago
so the age from that side is now kind of
in a gray area we're not really sure if
they're going to help but
i don't really want to be put in a
situation where i just get hit with a
bill all right so there's two nowhere
dave and hop in here there's two big
issues here okay issue number one is
you're about to marry somebody and y'all
have not
been able to have very basic
low
low-level
conflict agreement conversations
i cannot think of a bigger red flag
other than she's dating somebody else
because this will be a conversation
about what home we buy what neighborhood
what schools what kit this will go
you'll have this conversation a thousand
times
it just happens to be over a degree plan
and i personally and again dave may
disagree it's great i
if you have cash for this and you want
to get a master's degree to learn about
nutrition knock your lights out if you
can pay for it it's going to be a joint
decision it's something we're going to
do together and i'm going to use the
nutrition info for the kids great
if it's for a status symbol then you
might as well be buying a porsche that
you can't afford and you don't know how
anybody's going to pay for it right this
is the whole thing feels gross and then
you don't know who's going to pay for it
this whole thing's a mess man and the
fact that you guys had to discuss it
with both your parents is a weird thing
you're about to get married you're
grown-ups
the
you're about to be you're way down close
to the altar to be having this
discussion this late and not be in
agreement on it you guys need to sit
down with an emergency session with a
marriage counselor today today today
today this is this is this is like stop
them wedding type stuff this is about
communication less about the decline not
about the degree it's not about disagree
with the stupidity of the degree which i
do but that's a side issue yeah the the
issue is is that you guys do not know
how to have a discussion without you
ruining her dreams let me just tell you
after 40 years sharon ramsey has no
trouble ruining my dream thank god right
if she thinks that they're a nightmare